صوت مجلس النواب
على عزل رئيس الولايات
المتحدة للمرة الثالثة فقط في
التاريخ الأمريكي ،
واتهم دونالد جي ترامب بإساءة استخدام
سلطته وعرقلة عمل الكونجرس الآن
، ويجب على مجلس الشيوخ أن يقرر ما إذا كان
سيدينونه ويطرده من السلطة أم لا.
لقد حدث الكثير ليصل بنا إلى هذه النقطة ،
دعنا ننظر إلى الوراء كيف بدأ كل شيء
الآن ، أنت تعرف الآن قصة
الرئيس ترامب عن تجميد المساعدة العسكرية
لأوكرانيا في يوليو / تموز عندما تحدث مع
الرئيس الأوكراني عبر الهاتف وطلب
منه التحقيق مع منافسه السياسي جو
بايدن  بعد فترة وجيزة
من تلقي المفتش العام لمجتمع الاستخبارات
مايكل أتكينسون
شكوى للمخبرين تزعم أن
الرئيس ترامب ضغط على أوكرانيا
للتدخل في انتخابات 2020 ،
حاول البيت الأبيض التستر عليها ، وأرسل
أتكينسون الشكوى إلى القائم بأعمال
مدير المخابرات الوطنية
جوزيف ماكغواير وهذا  هو المكان الذي
تعطل فيه الأمور قانون المبلغين عن المخالفات الذي ينص
على أن المدير يجب أن يرسل الشكوى  في
الكونجرس لكن ماكجواير لا يفعل أن
هذه الشكوى مختلفة عن معظمها ، فهي
تتعلق برئيس ماكجواير
رئيس الولايات المتحدة ومحادثاته
مع زعيم أجنبي
وقد تخضع هذه المناقشات لامتياز تنفيذي
يتم حجبه عن الجمهور
لأغراض وطنية  أمنيًا أو
لحماية المداولات الداخلية ، وهو
امتياز ليس لدي
سلطة التنازل عنه ، فبدلاً من
إرسال الشكوى إلى الكونجرس يطلب mcguire
من البيت الأبيض التوجيه ، انتقلت
إلى موضوع الشكوى للحصول على المشورة
أولاً حول ما إذا كان يجب عليك
تقديم الشكوى  إلى الكونجرس ، أعتقد أن
كل شيء هنا في هذه المسألة غير
مسبوق تمامًا يقوم ماكجواير بإرسال
الشكوى إلى وزارة العدل
في هذه المرحلة ، حيث تسرق العملية هذا
عندما يقوم المفتش العام
بإبلاغ الكونغرس بوجود
الشكوى ويبدأ مجلس
النواب في  التحقيق
هناك سلسلة من التسريبات
والاتهامات مع  في
الشكوى العلنية ، هذا يضغط على
البيت الأبيض ويؤكد الرئيس ترامب
أنه ناقش
جو بايدن في مكالمته مع الرئيس الأوكراني
أن المكالمة كانت شركة رائعة هي
مكالمة مثالية حيث
يبدأ المنزل تحقيقًا بشأن عزله.
يجب أن
يحاسب الرئيس ، فلا أحد فوق القانون في
اليوم التالي ، رفع البيت الأبيض السرية عن
نسخة تقريبية من المكالمة ، وتم
إرسال شكوى المبلغين عن المخالفات إلى
الكونغرس ، وبدأ الديمقراطيون في
استدعاء موظفي السلطة
التنفيذية مهددين بتهديدهم بالازدراء إذا
لم يفعلوا ذلك.  يُظهر البيت الأبيض
يدفع للوراء قائلاً إن العملية برمتها غير
دستورية وتنتهك
حق الرئيس في الإجراءات القانونية الواجبة ، حيث
يتم تبني القرار دون اعتراض
، حيث يتم وضع اقتراح بإعادة النظر
على الطاولة
حتى يقوم البيت بإضفاء الطابع الرسمي على تحقيقه
بتصويت يُتوقع حدوثه.
خطوط الحزب وعقدت سلسلة من
جلسات الاستماع الخاصة والعامة وجدت
مكالمة هاتفية يوم 25 يوليو  غير معتاد لأنه على
عكس المكالمات الرئاسية الأخرى
التي لاحظتها ، فقد اشتملت على مناقشة
ما بدا أنه مسألة سياسية داخلية
لدي مخاوف وكان من واجبي
أن أبلغ عن وجود مقايضة كما
شهادتي سابقًا فيما يتعلق
بالبيت الأبيض المطلوب  المكالمة والاجتماع بالبيت الأبيض
، الجواب هو نعم ،
كان الجميع على دراية بالدستور الذي يقول إنه
يمكن مقاضاة الرئيس بسبب
الجرائم والجنح الجسيمة ، لكنه لا
يحدد ما تعنيه هذه المصطلحات ، الأمر
متروك للكونغرس والمجلس يقرر
المضي قدمًا في  تقدم لجنة مجلس النواب المعنية
بالقضاء مادتين من
إجراءات العزل تتهمان
رئيس الولايات المتحدة دونالد جيه ترامب
بارتكاب جرائم وجنح كبيرة وتتوجه
إلى قاعة مجلس النواب
للمناقشة ، ومن المؤسف أن تصرفات الرئيس
المتهورة تجعل من توجيه الاتهام
إلينا أمرًا ضروريًا.  لا خيار في تصويت
تاريخي يتهم فيه مجلس النواب
الرئيس ترامب بإساءة استخدام سلطته
و  عرقلة الكونجرس الآن تنتقل إلى
مجلس الشيوخ لمحاكمة حيث
ستكون هناك حاجة إلى أغلبية الثلثين
لإدانة
تيم وإقالته من منصبه في
غضون ذلك ، يستعد الرئيس ترامب
لإعادة انتخابه في عام 2020 ، مما يعني أنه
يجب على الديمقراطيين والجمهوريين القيام بعمل
محرج.  التوازن بين ممارسة
واجباتهم الدستورية وحماية
حياتهم السياسية